we're honored to have you
we've talked to one two three four five
six millionaires this hour 2.4 1.8 1.5
1.4 2.5 and 2.9 none of them were crooks
none of them were entertainers or
athletes
none of them inherited enough money that
it affected their or their net worth it
was all tiny amounts if they got any at
all none of them had four point two one
one had a 4.0 he was a college professor
and so all this stuff you hear about
millionaires is just not true those were
all regular people a lot of Engineers
been granted pharmacists in the mix
there a lot of teachers and even the
college professor was teaching at a PhD
and teaching engineering so I mean it
was just like the engineer day but
interesting these are people with a they
got 4-year degrees and they applied you
know that were applicable in the
marketplace they got up left the cave
killed something and drugged at home
they're not there they all said spend
less than you make they all said live on
a budget they all said debt did not call
it they didn't they go to some
get-rich-quick scheme on the weekend and
go you know ten million dollars in real
estate debt and nothing down and that
that's not how they got rich all of them
built their wealth slow and steady all
of them built their wealth slow and
steady they did the stuff we talked
about here every single day every one of
them I talked to they were identical
today it wasn't not even an outlier
sometimes we get an outlier somebody
that inherited it or sometimes we get an
outlier someone who borrowed a bunch of
money to create wealth and open the
business or something like that but but
today it was all slow and steady every
one of them all six of them see you have
to cut through the mythology that you're
broke friends with a political ideology
are yakking about over Thanksgiving or
you're broke family members because what
I'm trying to point out is they don't
know what the flip they're talking about
these are real millionaires I met with
these people for 25 30 years now and
every time I meet with them this is who
they are and when they walk in the lobby
of our building you can't tell who they
are they don't look any
different they don't they're not flashy
they're not wearing you know big watches
or big rings or you know a mr. t starter
kit around their neck or anything like
that they don't look like something that
you say on movie you know that's not
that you know it's not who they are they
enjoy their life they've lived like no
one else and now they're able to live
and give like no one else but this idea
that somehow you've done something wrong
if you built well that's got to stop in
this country we've taught people to not
be successful so we have a whole bunch
of people that they're being not
successful because they learned the
lesson well and we're gonna reverse the
trend here on the Dave Ramsey show we're
gonna show you what it looks like to win
and that winning is well it's a noble
thing that puts the sound of the Dave
Ramsey show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's altum Utley
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show